maybe I'll just okay what's up guys we
are finishing we're back with another
episode of challenge infinity our
special guest today is cassia she's not
very good at tricks but she's just hit
show a pretty place this video is
sponsored by ray corn his wireless
earbuds we'll talk more about later on
okay so is it possible to play with a
needle
[Applause]
[Music]
needle was quite important there but not
enough
[Music]
[Applause]
gotcha
it's much you can really feel that
something has destructive all you won't
expect this
[Music]
and I've never rushed there this is my
way to do it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay what's happening let's try playing
on auto shoulders let's go
for once you don't have to worry about
footwork someone else's so who else is
doing it for you we're unbeatable
[Music]
where's the footwork or thought or it
maybe I should be the one one below yeah
you should
[Applause]
yo nice
[Music]
okay so for the next challenge we need a
target the one who spins a different
color rather loses ready yeah I get to
eat some bubblegum sir I guess I'm the
real winner here I guess on the way over
here
[Applause]
[Music]
not bad okay so we have to do some
slight modifications for the net put it
like this yeah there bit of an operation
there is that's pretty good
I'm surprised well it looks quite good
this is some creative video shooting
[Applause]
[Music]
house a roller table suitable for around
the Nets I'm sure you're doing this
effective that technique
[Music]
[Applause]
what
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Raik on is a wireless audio technology
brand whose earbuds started about half
the price of other premium wireless
earbuds the audio quality is great and
are also perfect for practicing this
latest model e 25 with six hours play
time it also comes with a handy charging
case it's also suitable for our
alternates
so go to buy reckon calm /pha infinity
to get 15% off your order
brought to you by recon big thanks to
sponsoring this video so thank you okay
so you have been a great help today
don't forget to subscribe and what's up
previous leaders there until next time
case you're supposed to say until next
time